[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
going to be discussing Dumbledore
Grindelwald Draco Malfoy Voldemort Harry
Potter in the possession of the Elder
Wand now if you don't know what the
Elder Wand is then I don't know what
books you've been reading or movies
you've been watching but here's a brief
introduction to the Elder Wand for the
videos sake the Elder Wand was the first
hallo created made by Death himself it
was said to be the most powerful one
that ever existed the elder one is made
of alder wood and its core is the tail
hair of a thestral it's 15 inches long
and has carvings down its length that
resemble clusters of elderberries with
the Elder Wand witches and wizards are
able to effortlessly produce intensely
powerful magic that others could only
dream of possession of the wand also
meant that you could produce magic which
was not otherwise possible this includes
mending are the ones that could not
normally be repaired through magic it's
insanely powerful particularly in the
hands of an equally powerful witch or
wizard we see the elder one-pass hands
on numerous occasions in the Harry
Potter books and films but there seems
to be some misconceptions floating
around but how the ownership of the wand
is actually earned or transferred
without going too far back into the
one's ownership it belonged to the
following owners ukuko Gourevitch then
Gellert Grindelwald then Albus
Dumbledore then Draco Malfoy and then
Harry Potter we're led to believe that
the wand also belonged to both Snape and
Voldemort but this was never the case
they had the wand in their possession
but they weren't the true owners the
wand hadn't chosen them
so if acquiring it and having it in your
possession doesn't necessarily mean that
Elder Wand is yours then how do you
claim ownership of it how does the wand
choose you let's first take a look at
how the wand was acquired by each of the
above we don't actually know how miku
korvac obtained the wand but we do know
that Brenda Wald became the owner by
stealing it from him
Dumbledore later defeats Grindelwald in
a duel and becomes the rightful owner of
the wand himself many many years later
Draco Malfoy disarms Dumbledore and
becomes the new owner then Harry Potter
trots along and snatches the one for
himself Harry Potter only has the one in
his possession for a short period before
disposing of it so we can see here that
the wand transfers ownership in a couple
of different ways where it was
previously thought
particularly by Voldemort that gained
ownership with the wand required murder
all of the above contradicts this and
this was one of Voldemort's fatal errors
in his battle against Harry just because
he had the wand in his possession he
didn't show allegiance to him
it showed allegiance to Harry many
believe that because Grindelwald stole
the Elder Wand from kerkovich
rather than killing him he was never the
true owner this would mean that
Dumbledore who acquired the wand after
defeating Grindelwald wasn't the true
owner either but this doesn't work with
the story at all as it would mean that
no one after kerkovich was actually a
true owner of the wand that's why the
notion of murdering to acquire it makes
absolutely no sense in order to acquire
the wand you need to best or defeat the
current owner of the wand but that isn't
limited to murder that means that you
can disarm them or do whatever it is
that you need to to obtain the wand no
killing is necessary and that's why
something as simple as a disarming charm
or a stunning spell can work we seek
Rinda Walt - just this and now Harry was
hurrying along a dark corridor and stout
little grigorevich is awake as he held a
lantern aloft grigorevich burst into the
room at the end of the passage and his
lantern illuminated what looked like a
workshop wood shavings in gold gleamed
in the swinging pool of light and there
on a window ledge sat perched like a
giant bird
young man with golden hair in the split
second that the lanterns light
illuminated him how I saw the to light
upon his handsome face then the intruder
shot a stunning spell from his wand and
jumped neatly backward out of the window
with a crow of laughter so defeat isn't
limited to death which means that you
can gain ownership by just overpowering
the current owner JK Rowling expanded on
how the elder one chooses ownership in
an interview the Elder Wand is simply
the most ruthless of ones and that it
will only take into consideration
strength one would expect a certain
amount of loyalty from one's wand so
even if you were to Psalm 2 while
carrying it even if you lost a fight
while carrying it it has developed an
affinity with you that it won't give up
easily
if however a wand is one properly won in
an adult jewel then a wand may switch
allegiance
however the Elder Wand knows no loyalty
except his strength it's completely
unsentimental it will only go where the
power is so if you win then you've won
the wand you don't need to kill with it
but almost inevitably it attracts
wizards who are prepared to kill and who
will kill and also it attracts with it's
like Voldemort who confused being
prepared to murder with strength and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please be sure to like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]